dans la bataille contre les énergies
fossiles grégory mike houghton a perdu
une manche
professeur à mcgill depuis 18 ans il
enseigne dans les département de
philosophie et d'environnement spéciaux
extinction l'extinction d'espèces
d'animaux l'acidification des océans
les incendies les inondations la
sécheresse il ne peut plus ignorer la
réalité
grégory mac os ce n'est le sénat du
campus ont demandé trois fois à
l'université de retirer ses
investissements des énergies fossiles en
décembre mais il a refusé encore c'est
une immense carte parce que la
contribution de précaution n'était a été
incroyable au fait les années membre du
groupe des vestes mais guéri
annabelle et d'autres étudiants
manifestent depuis 2012 pour le
désinvestissement sans succès jusqu'ici
il refuse de reconnaître le tort grave
causée par l'industrie dans un courriel
une porte parole rappelle que
l'université est déterminé à réduire
l'empreinte carbone de ses
investissements incluant ceux dans
l'industrie des énergies fossiles mais
pour l'instant ces investissements
représentent toujours 8,7 pour cent du
portefeuille de mpt et guile soit des
dizaines de millions de dollars à
vancouver des étudiants qui ont fait la
grève de la faim pendant des jours la
semaine dernière ont eu gain de cause
l'université de la colombie britannique
a promis de retirer ses bd énergies
fossiles elle rejoint d'autres
universités canadiennes qui ont fait des
promesses similaires dont l'uqam et
concordia
le combat est en cours partout en
novembre des étudiants des universités
harvard et yale ont envahi le terrain
lors de matches de football entre les
deux équipes
cet étudiant de harvard crois que la
manifestation a marqué un point tournant
aux etats unis le mouvement dit elle
reçoit même la pluie de candidats à la
présidence dont bunny 102 jusqu'ici une
cinquantaine d'universités américaines
ont promis de décarboniser et leurs
portefeuilles
un geste à forte teneur symbolique croit
grégory macau sun pour lui il ne fait
aucun doute que l'université emboîtera
le pas tôt ou tard ici sébastien
desrosiers radio-canada mourir